[Applaudissements]
j'adore ce sera sérieux mais gilles
entraînons connard je suis incapable de
présenter l'émission tout seul non plus
à ça c'est quand même pas compliqué de
se jeter des merguez îles neptune péri
quand on fait un don de lait coule un
bon cyril était là ouais ouais ouais son
turban des weight et atrocités de cette
voie qu'elle a choisie à l'effet tapie
ma fille a surpris
[Applaudissements]
m
ceux ci
non mais c'est l'anniversaire de jean
michel mr a besoin de ça c'était la
surprise et quoi président michel alary
et voilà sur 22 ans michel
ouais ouais c'est rien volé un truc
c'est que j'ose le dvd un top 10 j'adore
la scène est monté sur scène j'avais là
j'espère qu'ils un drone j'espère qu'il
va me prendre je vous ai pris un chic au
courant alors on va se rapprocher un
tout petit peu dans la lumière des
projecteurs
j'ai envie de chanter on va se calmer on
va juste prospère à bout du compte il a
fait un peu mal de mer mer j'ai un coup
de gueule